she stars in the new movie it's called
the shape of water it is a fairy tale
set in the 1960s where a mute woman
falls in love with a creature and it is
a creature held captive in a government
lab Spencer's character tries to help
her friend save the creature before he
is dissected and killed
looking like you don't know anything
what help me if they ask me about you
I'm not a good liar except Proust it
takes a lot alas Keep America / marriage
going Octavia Spencer welcome back to
the table thank you for having breasts
the shape of water I have to tell you I
don't even know how to describe what I
saw yesterday it is so well done it's
it's been described as weird wonderful
one of the best films of the year and
you are so good and the movie is so good
oh no you said that you liked it the
minute you read the first scene how is
that possible what did you see well I'm
a huge guillermo del toro fantasy i
wrecked it and just about everything
he's executive produced and he's in our
tour he had true our tour and when it
what the first scene when everything is
underwater I said oh my god they're
gonna be doing things like this I want
to be a part of this movie so I knew it
would be magical he said he wrote it for
you
what does that mean to you you two met
we met and it was supposed to be we were
supposed to discuss the movie for about
30 minutes over coffee in three hours
later we still hadn't talked about the
movie we talked about every talking
about a life love antiques our love of
antiques dieting I mean everything while
it's a sci-fi movie spoiler alert it's
not based on a true story it does
address issues at the time and that
we're currently facing as well I'm one
of the villains in the movie Michael
Shannon said to you that the Lord looks
a lot like a human like you or maybe a
little more like me him being a white
man comparing a sea creature obviously
to yourself and and a woman at the time
I mean it stood out to me well it's
interesting because Guillermo is
latin-american Canadian and so he is
also used to being considered the other
and and the wonderful thing about this
being a fairy tale is that he can
address those political issues without
pointing fingers his two main characters
can't speak so he uses marginalized
people within society a black female
janitor a closeted gay man and Richard
second scare achter to characterize the
the social mores of the day and so I
think it's interesting that he's able to
weave that into the story and my
character not have to play to that for
the first time me and your character
Zelda the black female janitor described
a little bit about her that friendship -
well Zelda is a woman of the times I
mean it's 1962 black people don't have
the right to vote so she's considered a
second-class citizen with within society
but within her world of this facility
she's a queen I mean you know she talks
non-stop best friends with Eliza Sally
Hawkins character plays a mute woman who
plays a mute woman and she's also the
voice of that character and when she's
in scenes with her so it was a wonderful
progression of friendship both in real
life and on screen to get to play that
opposite Sally you know but you know
what it showed me because when you first
see the sea creature he is quite
unattractive but by the time the movie
ends you see I saw him totally different
after a while he seemed I don't want to
say handsome but you felt a tenderness
in connection and it just said to me
that to smite evil in the bigotry
kindness and empathy can always prevail
you can always find that well that is
also the meaning of the film the shape
of water is the shape of love and love
takes on the vessel of the shape of the
vessel so if you are an ugly person then
the shape of your water is going to be
quite ugly but if you're a loving person
then you can see past the differences
and that's one of the beautiful things
of the movie do you know you're coming
into your own Octavia Spencer you talk
about being in your 20s and being in
your 30s and being in your 40s and now
being your whatever over the course of
your life what do you think about those
decades in your life well in your 20s
you you really do spend your time
wondering and caring about what other
people think and you should and in your
30s you take a little ownership and
start seeing yourself for who you are
and by your 40s and I'm I'm gonna say
mid-40s but it's kind of latter end of
it I I just I realized I I don't have to
care that much about what other people
think because at
end of the day if I'm being the best
person that I can be that's all I can
offer and if it's not good enough well
then honey I'm not gonna lose any sleep
over it so yes I am I feel like I am
coming into my own and I do think that
happens in your 40s too don't you guys
will you start thinking I feel okay
about myself and as long as I feel good
about myself and the people I care about
because there's always going to be
chatter about you right the confidence
is there you will always have detractors
that is one truth and you could be the
best person possible but someone will
find a fault with you so when you
realize that and and understand that as
long as you try to be the best person
you can be that's all you can offer do
beyond what you have to look forward to
I'm almost there
two months away man thank you so much
and the shape of water opens in select
theaters nationwide on Friday